the first time i heard about vpns was
from the many sponsorships from my
favorite youtubers and chances are
you have as well but what are vpns and
more importantly
how can they benefit gaming i should
clarify upfront that we are
not sponsored by a vpn for this video
however if you are interested in one you
can check out a couple of our favorites
in the description below a vpn stands
for virtual private network
they are private more secure connections
that allow users to send encrypted data
safely
whether it's sending important files
over a secure line or browsing
websites without being tracked a vpn is
a safer way to use the internet
they keep websites and applications from
tracking you and encrypting your traffic
something that is particularly useful if
you're browsing on public wi-fi
there's also the more recreational
purpose such as changing your ip address
so you can watch anime not available in
your country's version of netflix
a vpn service such as expressvpn are
commercialized vpns that let users
tunnel their internet traffic into the
vpn
server this changes your ip address
shielding your
real ip address from others now vpns
have long been used by companies to move
sensitive files but thanks to commercial
vpns the average person can take
advantage of them as well
now when it comes to gaming with vpns
the advantages are a little more niche
but still there for starters just like
with streaming services
vpns can be used to download games not
available
in your region for example before
fortnite was officially released in
china
chinese players would use vpns to access
the game
if you live in north america where we
have access to most games
this isn't going to be as high of a
necessity but
there still are region specific games
you won't be able to get access to
unless you use a vpn there are a wealth
of games not made available yet such as
last year's beta for the mmorpg
blue protocol which american players
could check out
thanks to vpns but please keep in mind
that while using a vpn this way is legal
it may violate the terms and services of
a particular platform
for example steam's subscriber agreement
states that
you will not use ipproxying or other
methods to disguise the place of your
residence
whether to circumvent geographical
restrictions on game content
to purchase at pricing not applicable to
your geography
or for any other purpose if you do this
valve may terminate your access to your
account
so the prospect of playing foreign games
is exciting
but potentially risky so make sure to do
your homework beforehand
now where vpns can really come in handy
is in the world of online gaming thanks
to a vpn you can connect to a server you
don't normally have access to which
allows you to play with
people in other countries with the
understanding that your
connection is going to take a hit as a
result now you might be wondering if
vpns can lead to a more stable
connection
keep in mind that a vpn isn't a
replacement for your
internet service provider but one you
use on top of it
if you already have a fast connection a
vpn isn't gonna do much to help boost
you
it may however cause less strain when
playing a game that uses a peer-to-peer
connection
peer-to-peer or p2p is when there is no
dedicated server that players connect to
instead they connect directly to each
other as a result if you
or the people you are playing with have
rough connections this will
lead to laggy experiences powerful vpns
with high speeds
can potentially help reduce ping and
smooth
everything out but there's another very
important reason to use a vpn with a p2p
game and that is for security
using a vpn can help prevent against
ddos attacks which is essentially when a
server or
network is jammed up preventing its use
somebody can easily target an individual
as long as they have their ip address
this has been a tried and true tactic to
mess up game servers
streamers or players in persistent
online games such as
eve a solid prevention strategy is using
a vpn to
hide your ip address you might be
thinking to yourself that no one's gonna
bother attacking you
the average player that's mostly true
most games rely on dedicated servers and
the idea that you'll be attacked
just isn't likely gonna happen but you
are significantly more at risk if you
play games that use p2p
such as the insanely popular gta online
as well as its counterpart red dead
online
these games are well documented for
their poor security
and it's really easy for a cheater to
use ddos attacks on other players
because they were
upset at a loss or just wanted to be a
dick
if you're somebody that likes playing
p2p games like gta online regularly
a vpn can be a valuable prevention tool
to help keep you safe now these are all
great ways to use a vpn for
gaming but it's up to you to decide if
it's worth the cost
after all vpn services can run anywhere
from five to twelve dollars a month
free vpns do exist but they aren't truly
free you're instead paying with your
info
that they collect and then sell to third
parties which
to me kinda defeats the point of using
one vpn services
also have different priorities in what
they offer
for gaming you'll want one that
emphasizes speed
and doesn't offer any data caps
expressvpn nordvpn
and ipvanish are some of the top offers
currently available
as mentioned before we have links in the
description if you're interested
but that's about going to do it for me
and this video hopefully you guys
learned something about vpns
i don't think they're necessary for
gaming but i do think they have their
advantages especially when it comes to
playing
p2p games now if you enjoyed explanation
videos like this one
i've done a couple i did a great one on
hdmi 2.1
and you know whether it's worth
investing in that whole nonsense
ecosystem buying cables and tvs and all
that
we also have a is it worth it series
where we talk about expensive versus
inexpensive hardware dave did a great
one on gaming mice so if you're
interested in that
please go check that out my name is john
luke thanks for watching and i'll see
you all next time